Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz
bugün stoğa felsefesi hakkında ben
konuşmak istiyorum milattan önce 3
yüzyılda kapısı Zeno tarafından kurulmuş
olan bir felsefe ekolü bu Fakat ben
birazdan modern suarcılıktan
bahsedeceğim erken sporculuk Yunan
dönemi daha sonra Roma döneminde esas en
böyle şaşalı zamanlarında yaşayan bir
felsefe bu seneca maruz gibi
filozoflarda daha sonra rönesans
döneminde
biraz daha Hristiyan yönelinde bir
yorumuyla
neonstrojen adıyla tekrardan canlanmış
ve şu anda Çağdaş sporcu olarak hala
hayatta olan bir felsefe akımı bugünkü
konuşmamı biraz daha iyi oluşla alakalı
Çünkü Şifa temasıyla konuşuyoruz biraz
daha iyi oluşla alakalı olan kısımları
üzerinden ele almaya çalışacağım
iyi yaşam stockcıların en çok
kendilerini meşhur
ettiklerini iyi yaşayan sorusu iyi yaşam
ının
iyi olmayan bir yaşamdan ne farkı vardır
sorusuna cevapları Erdemli bir yaşam
oldu yani Erdemli yaşam iyi yaşamdır
erdemden ne anlıyorlardı peki
doğaya uygun bir yaşam Erdemli yaşamdır
Peki doğadan kasıt ne ondan bahsedeceğim
bu tür bir yaşamın Erdemli yaşamı doğayı
uygun bir yaşamın aynı zamanda
huzurlu ve mutlu bir hayat olacağını da
söylüyorlar
doğayı uygun yaşamayı nasıl
anlayabiliriz tuhaf felsefesi içerisinde
doğaya uygun yaşamak
doğaya uygun Yaşamak Demek gerçeklerle
yüzleşerek yaşamakta var
onları içselleştirebilmek Demek
gerçekten içselleştirme gerçeklerle
beraber yaşayabilmek demek
dirençsizce bir yaşam gibi düşünebiliriz
buna özellikle zihinsel olarak
burada Peki hangi Gerçeklerden
bahsediyoruz insana dair gerçekler Bu
çok çok önemli insana dair gerçekler
Bir de dair gerçekten
bu dünyaya dair
e etrafınızda olan şeyleri yüzleşebilmek
onları kabullenebilme insana daire
Gerçeklerden ve en önemlisi iki tane
temel özellikten bahsedeceğim temel
gerçekten bahsedeceğim insana dair
insanın akılsal bir varlık olduğu
gerçeğiyle yüzleşmemiz gerekiyor Bu ne
demek
Mesela şunu düşünelim
bir şempanze düşünelim
şeyh hazretleri biliyorsunuz erkek
şempanzeler arasında sık görülen bir
davranış var Diğer erkek şempanzelerin
yavrularını öldürüyor bazı erkekler bu
sık görülen bir davranışlar bu olan bir
şey şimdi diyelim ki
bir
Maymunlar Cehennemi belki
biliyorsunuzdur
o filmlerde bu maymunlar ve kuyruksuz
maymunlar insan seviyesinde biliş ve
pirinç kazanıyorlar pil yetenek
atıyorlar düşünme yetenek atıyorlar akıl
kazanıyorlar bizim seviy
emizde yani 3-4 tane versiyonu var
diyelim ki bir şempanze bu şekilde insan
kapasitesinde akıl kazandı bir iş
kazandı bilinç kazandı bir yetenek
kazandı hepsini kazandı Ondan sonra
tekrar böyle gitti başka bir
erkek şempanzelim yavrusunu şey yapıyor
Şimdi siz bunu gördünüz bu artık insan
seviyesinde bir bilgiçe sahip o zaman Ne
dersiniz yani ne yapıyorsun koko
yapma ya ben şempanze'yi mi Ben içimden
böyle geliyor bu bedenin böyle bir dürtü
var Benim için de dese O zaman ne
diyeceksin sen atamam şempanzeysen tamam
o zaman demeyeceğiz o zaman diyeceğiz ki
hayır ama bir dakika sen şu anda karar
verme yeteneğine de sahipsin içinden
gelen gürültüleri değerlendirme ve takip
edip etmemeye karar vermemek yeteneğine
sahipsin bu kapasiteye sahipsin artık o
mazeretin yok içinden geliyor olması
mazeret değil artık çünkü akıl ortaya
çıktı mı bir türde artık o türün doğası
akıldan ibaret hale geliyor Bu
biyolojik şeylerin seni belirlemiyorlar
Sen Aklında o biyolojik özelliklerin
değerlendirebilirsin yargılayabilirsin
takip edip etmemeye karar verebilirsin
bu yüzleşmemiz gereken bir şey çünkü bu
bize sorumluluk veriyor
aklen baktığımızda kendimize
özgürlüğümüzün sınırında olduğunu da
görüyoruz ama bazı şeylere karar
veriyoruz Bunu işimizasyon dürtünün
gelmesi yeterli oluyor Biz
değerlendiriyoruz ahlaki değerlerimize
göre başka değerlerimize göre Ama bazı
şeyler bizim kontrolümüz altında Bazı
şeylerde değil bazı şeyler gücümüzle
dairede bazı şeyler değil
bunu su ağacındaki en önemli yüzleşmemiz
gereken şeylerden bir tanesi bu
düşündüğümüzde
alıcılar gücümüz halinde bazı şeyler
gücümüz halinde değil şimdi eğer bir şey
gücümüz dahilinde
değil bunun hakkında endişelenmek
hayıflanma kaygılanmak anksiyeti
hissetmek makul biriyim Eğer gücünüz
halinde değilse onun hakkında da
endişelenmeyip kendimize zarar ver
başka eğer o şey gücümüz dahilinde ise
onun hakkında anksiyeti duymak
endişelenmek kaygılanmak korkmak o makul
mü O da değil Çünkü gücümüz dahilinde
zaten yapabiliriz gene bir kere gerek
yok falan bu durumda stoğacılar diyorlar
ki gerçekten böyle negatif duygular
diyorlar bunları korku gibi kaygı gibi
bu gibi duygular bize huzurunuzu bozan
bu duygular Aslında makul duygular değil
o halde akılcı bir yaşam yaşarsak o
duygulara yer kalmayacak git bile
azalacaklar kocaları söküp atmaktan
bahsetmiyorum sana gitgide onlara
ihtiyaç duymayan bir hayat
yaşayabileceğiz Böylece
mesela
dinindeki bir sunum yapacaksınız
Bu sunumu arkadaşlar çıkarsınız
çıkacaksınızdan konuşurken bile o
karıştıracaksınız falan böyle kelimeler
unutacaksınız neden bahsettiğinizi
olabilir diye düşünüyorsanız şimdi Ondan
sonra ne olacak
kırmızı şey gibi trafik lambası gibi o
kırmızı Ondan sonra ses sistemi nefes
şey olmaya falan değil mi Hani böyle
şimdi Ben bunu düşünüyorum Mesela benim
kontrolüm altında Eğer ben böyle bir şey
yaparsam ve benim başıma böyle bir şey
gelirse ben yine gelince hazırlandığım
halde insan olduğum için böyle bir şey
başıma gelirse ve insanlar da bana Böyle
gülersen hiçbir zaman olmaz böyle bir
şey ama diyelim ki oldu yani falan
güllerle geldi
yapılan yanlış benim bana değil onlara
ait
bu bana bir zarar vermez Çünkü benim
hayatımın amacı doğaya
uygun bir otelden bir yaşam O zaman ben
kendime soruyorum Benim Yüzümün
kızarması söyleyeceğimi insan olduğum
için unutmam hazırlanmış olduğum halde
unutmam bu beni daha kötü bir sayfa ama
erdemsiz bilgisayardan Hayır sorun yok o
zaman
kontrolüm altında olamadıklarım nedir
peki kontrolün altında olan kendi
eylemlerin
kendi mesela hazırlanmam yeterince
hazırlanmam mesela böyle bir şey varsa
böyle bir ihtimalle değerlendirelim Bu
şekilde bir yaklaşım bizim akıl
sağlığımız Ayrıca insanın toplumsal bir
varlık olması da yüzleşmemiz gereken
diğer temel gerçek insanı da var
burada
ıq'sis diye bir kavramları var o ikons
Ev yuva demek ekonomik oradan bir
ekoloji oradan geliyor mesela
oyunbozinozis'te Evet davet Evet dahil
etme gibi osmosisteki ebedi tatile girip
Ev halkına şöyle
hepimizin toplumsal varlık olarak Eğer
böyle tamamen böyle psikopat bir
insandan falan bahsetmiyorsan çok büyük
bir işsizliklerden bahsetmiyorsa
kendimizi değer veriyoruz Tabii ki
kendimize değer veriyoruz kendi
mutluluğumuza değer veriyoruz
reformumuza fakat başkalarının da en
azından çoluğunu çocuğunun ya da
arkadaşının akrabasının Neyse bir Yani
şöyle bir bizim önemseme dairemiz var bu
dairenin içindeki insanlar Biz
önemsiyoruz kendimiz de oradayız birkaç
tane En azından birkaç tane
etrafımızdaki insanlar olabilir Bunlar
akraba olabilir Başka bir şey olabilir o
eğitimsiz kavramı şöyle bir şey bunları
bu dairenin dışında Bazı insanların
bırakmak için Akli sebebimiz var mı yok
mu ben bazı insanların önemsiyorum Ondan
sonra Ha tamam bu Dairenin içinde o
insan Ama bu araçta insanlar şu insanı
ben
bunu cinsiyetinden dolayı neden etmesi
sesinden dolayı neden cinsel
yöneliminden dolayı neden işte bir
şeyinden birisinin renginden alıp
bunların hiçbirisi Akli sebepler değil
bir insana önemsememekle önemseme
dairesinin içinde bırakmak için o zaman
o iki husus anlayışı diyor ki herkesi
kat herkesi önemsemen lazım
bu Bununla da Yüzleşme özel Bu da bize
Tabi yükümlülükler veriyor etrafımızda
olanları görmezden gelmemek konusunda
yükümlü Bir de etrafımızda olanlar var
işte dediğim gibi dünyaya dair gerçekler
dünyadaki adaletsizlikleri falan
görüyoruz mesela bunu demek gözümüzü
kapamamalıyız bunları görmeliyiz fakat
Ondan sonra da bunları görünce Tamam ama
ben ne yapabilirim diye düşünmek
küçüklüğüm yapabileceğim yardım
edebileceklerimizi odaklanıyoruz Bazen o
bizim cesaretimizi kuruyor ama bizim
herkese yardım edemeyecek olmamız yardım
edebileceklerimizi görmezden gelmek için
bize bir Akli bir sebep sunuyor
bu bütüncül anlayışla
doğaya uygun yaşamak bunlara uygun
Yaşamak bu gerçeklere uygun yaşam
ve bu da ergenlik bir yaşam onlara göre
şimdi akılcı düşünelim o zaman madem
öyle aklımızı kullanıp düşünelim
aklımızı kullanarak
hayatımıza bir amaç belirlememiz
gerektiğini söylüyor Sokrates Burada
sorgulanmamış hayat Yaşamaya değmez
neden sorgulamamışlar Hayat Yaşamaya
değmez işte akılcı bir varlık olarak
hayatımızı sorgulamamız lazım neden
sorgulamazsam yani büyük sorular
Sormazsam hayatıma dair ne için
yaşıyorum Amacım ne olmadı değerlerimle
alakalı sorular Sormazsam boşta
kalmayacağım ona belirlenecek benim için
zaten kim tarafından belli edecek İşte
ailem tarafından olabilir okul
tarafından olabilir devlet tarafından
olabilir şirketler var işte onları
reklamları tarafını Her neyse Fakat
onların kaynağı ben olmayacağım
dışarıdan bana Bunlar verilmiş olacaklar
Neden bana Benim için ya da bana
yaratılan bir rolü oynuyor olacağım
başka biri de oynayabilirdi hani ben en
olduğum için yaşıyor olmak o hayatı Eğer
sorgulayıp da kendi kararlarını
doğrultusunda amaçlarını kendi
belirlemediysem Bunun için çok çok
önemli neden sorgulamamışlar geçemediği
var Çünkü o benim hayatım olmaz zaten
gerçekten benim hayatıma olmaz otantik
bir hayat olmasın o zaman bir amaç bile
vermemiz lazım
Bunun içinde seneta diyor ki genç dönem
Roma döneminde hangi limana erken
açtığını bilmeyene hiçbir Rüzgar
yardımcı olamaz
Bu Limanda Bu arada
en amacı olacak bu işte
boylamında bilmenize gerek yok Bu arada
bu limanın kuzeydoğu'da olduğunu
bilseniz yola çıkarsınız gitgide ona
yaklaştıkça daha da önemlisi
göreceksiniz zaten
kendi doğayı uygun yaşamın ne olduğunu
tam böyle algoritmik olarak bana liste
olarak ver sorusuna gerek olmalı
olmadığı düşüncesi burada aşağı yukarı
biliyoruz bunun ne demek olduğunu
aklıyla aklına uygun yaşamın
Bir de şu soru sorulabilir Tamam ama bu
hayatım için belirlediğim amaç yani
erdemli ve doğaya uygun yaşama amacı ya
da herhangi başka bir amaç hayatın
anlamına da amacına dair nesnel mi yoksa
öznel mi hani nesnelsea orada var
keşfediyorum öznelsea ben kendi için
belirliyorum bu sorunun çok önemli
olduğunu düşünmüyorum ben felsefi olarak
önemli gibi duruyor ama bence pratikte
pek önemli bir Çünkü Önemli olan
rasyonel bir amaç bulmak
mesela akılcı varlıklar olduğumuzu kabul
ediyorsa ve bu amaç hayatın amacı akla
uygunsa yani nesnelerse nesneldir öznel
söylesinler diye Sonuçta aklıma Uygundur
nesnelse de aklımı kullanarak bulacağım
özlerse de yazı tura atmayacağım aklını
kullanarak karar vereceğim sana
belirleyeceğim her halükarda rasyonel
şimdi o zaman düşünelim genelde iyi bir
yaşam için düşünen mutlu bir yaşamdan
mutluysa İyidir ki bu doğru olarak hani
mutlu bir yaşam diğer şeyler eşit olmak
kaydıyla Mutlu Yaşam mutsuz yaşamda
Tabii ki
iyidir ama bu tek önemli şey mutluluk mu
ayrı mevzu ve mutlulukla genelde haz
olarak anlaşılabiliyor bazen
o zaman düşünelim Acaba böyle mi
Gerçekten mi stajlar katılmıyor Ama
neden katılmıyor da
çünkü kötü hazlar da olabilir
zevk haz kötü de olabilir misal diyelim
ki size bir haber verdi Haber Geldi
Dediler ki bak tanıdığım birisinin bir
kavgaya karıştı hemen koştuğumuz
gittiğimizde oraya baktınız bir insan
başka birisini dövüyor
ve sizin tanıdığınız kişi şey yapar
saldırıya uğrayan kişi Belki yiyor
olabilir
sevdiğiniz biri işte anneniz babanız
kardeşiniz Neyse en yakın arkadaşınız
bu Tabii ki çok kötü bir şey Çünkü acı
çekiyor Bu çok kötü bir şey Tamam onun
için üzülürsünüz yani gayet iyi ikinci
senaryo yok gelmiş işte kavga var
gidiyorsun bu sefer döven sizin
tanıdığınız ve diyelim ki başkasının
dövüyor böyle masum bir insanın dövüyor
ve onu döverken de böyle çok da şey
yapıyor zevk alıyor diye böyle vuruyor
onu dövüyor Siz bunu
gördü dersinde şey mi dersiniz ya Ne
güzel bak mutlu benim işte tanıdım İşte
benim akrabam benim için onun adına
sevinir misiniz Çünkü mutlu yani
döverken yoksa daha mı beter
düzülürsünüz Hani stoacci bir bakış
açısından kurban olmaktan kurbağa kurban
olmak
Saldırgan olmaya iyi eğlenir Aslında
salgın ama çok da çok erkensiz olan o
önce bazılar kötü olabiliyor demek ki
ondan haz almasa daha iyi
zorlanmış olsa onu dövmeye zevk almasa
daha iyi Demek ki yani
mutluluk vermeyen hazlar'dan
bahsedebiliriz nedense nazlardan
bahsediyorum burada ya Mesela diyelim ki
işte bu şey dondurma benimle diyabetim
var iremem gerektiğini düşünüyorum hemen
gerektiğini biliyorum fakat bunu
görüyorum ve
dayanamıyorum yani çünkü
ve biyolojik olarak da bu bana haz
veriyor zaten haz verdiği için yiyorum
ben bunu ama bir yandan da düşünüyorum
ya ben ne iradesiz insanım yani benim
bunu yemem gerektiğini biliyorum ben bir
türlü yemeyeceğim demiştim kendime söz
vermiştim
haz veriyor Fakat mutluluk vermiyor tam
tersine huzurumu bozuyor diyebiliriz
bunun için tam tersine mutluluğumu
bozuyor diyebiliriz demek mutluluk
vermeyen pazardadır
Ayrıca hepimizin bildiği
bazıları olumsuz sonuçları olması
gelecekte Hani bunu da hesaba katmak
gerekiyor birden hedonizm ya da
havacılık parodisi olarak bilinen Has
peşinde koşmanın kendisinin haz
vermemesi durumu önce paradoksal olarak
hazzı Eğer hayatınızın amacı alırsa
o amaca erişmemizi engellemesi onu amaç
edinmenin o amaca ulaşmayı engellemesi
durum bunu alternatif olarak
story'cıların Biraz önce söylediğim gibi
perdem zaten Erdem yaşarsam mutlu
olacaksın diyorlar Neden sen haz
anlamında değil Ama huzur anlamında ve
neşeleşse bir iş gibi şeyler anlamadı
erdemden kasıklarımın çok mu kısa sürede
söyleyeyim 4 tane temel erdemden
bahsediyorlar Bunlar sokrates'ten gelen
hani
doğayı olacağını söylüyorlar bunlar
şimdi o zaman hayatınız Tuhafiye amacını
şu şekilde özetleyebilirim
gitgide daha Erdemli bir yaşam sürmek bu
çok önemli bu ileride edinilecek bir
amaç değil çok erkenci bir insan olmak
bile değil amaç git bile daha Erdemli
olun gitgide kendini dönüştürmek gitgide
kendini geliştirmek yani her an
ulaşabileceğimiz bir amaç bu yolda
çiziyor artık her an da ulaşıyoruz bu
amacı sürekli bir amaç ileride bir varış
noktası olarak değil
bunu şöyle diyebilirsiniz Yani kendimi
odaklanmak Sadece bu çok bencilce bir
şey değil yani kendini geliştirme
kendini dönüştürmek Ama bu çok bencillik
amaçlı olmadığını Hayır çünkü ağaç gibi
düşünün Hani ağacın bakımını yapmanız
ağacın gelişimine katkıda bulunmaz
Aslında meyvaların o ağaç daha sonra
topluma etkili
katkıda bulunacak etrafına katkıda
bulunacak yani ağacın sağlıklı olması
Herkes için iyi Başka bir örnek
verdikleri kalp gibi düşün mesela kalpin
içerisindeki
şey gibi vücudun içerisine kalp Kalbin
sağlıklı olması bir cümle sağlıklı
olması ve siz Kalbe odaklanırsınız onu
sağlık yaparsınız Bu
vücut bunu şöyle düşünebiliriz
Peki nasıl olacak bu
çekiç
Bu şey gibi düşünün Hani bu çekicinin
rengi pek iyi değil gibi duruyor ben
beğenmiyorum Bununla ilgili Ama ben bunu
çekici alıp da kullandığımda bir şey
için benim
Aynı bunun gibi başımıza gelen namoş
olaylar olabilir Bunları alıp da eğer
ben daha erdemli bir insan olmak için
kullanırsan artık onları ben şey yapmış
olurum Hani film üzerindeki olumsuz
etkilerini bertaraf etmiş olurum ve
onlarla kendimi daha da güçlendiririm
aslında
burada
Erdem ve atakaya dediklerimi mutluluk
arasında şöyle bir ilişkiden
bahsedebiliriz
insan küçüklüğünden dolayı Ya zaten
hayatınızın amacı erdemde
Olmaktır değil erdemli olmak için
kullanabileceği için de hayal
kırıklığına uğramamak kendi elindedir Bu
yüzden papatya'ya yani kötü duyguların
olmadığı bir huzur var anne haklısın
kötü duyguların olmadığı bir
huzur haline ulaşması kolaydır
huzurluysa da daha ergenliğe bir insan
olarak yaşaması daha kolaydır Çünkü
olumsuz Duygulardan özgürleşir mümkün
olduğunca %100 Tabii ki biyolojik bir
şeyimizden dolayı yapamıyoruz ama şöyle
düşünün Ben bazen derslerde sorarım
psikolojik hakkında
bir baba çocuğunun parktayız oynarken
birisi Kazan saldırıya uğradığını görse
ve hiç sinirlenmesin
birçok kişi varmıyor genelde de
öğrenciler der ki vardır Neden Çünkü
kurtarması lazım çocuğunu yani çocuğunun
şeye alacaksın ama ben çocuğunu
kurtarmaya çalışmadı demedim Sadece öfke
olmadı
dedi
ihtiyaç duymadan çocuğunu kurtarmaya
çalışabilir ve hatta öfkelenmeden yapsa
daha da iyi olur büyük ihtimalle Hani
çünkü kalkan zararla oturur bir köpek
saldırırsa mesela çocuğuna köpeği
öfkelenmek zorunda mı Adam köpeği
öfkelenmeden kurtarabilir önemsememekten
bahsetmiyorum sevmemekten bahsetmiyorum
Aynı bunun gibi stoacılara göre öfke
nefret ki kıskançlık gibi kötü duyguları
ihtiyaç duymadan iyi bir şekilde yaşayan
insanlara dönüşmemiz mümkün
soruyorlar seninkaya askerlerin de
öfkelenmesini istemezsin savaşta
öfkelensinler ki atlasınlar şey düşman
sene kadar diyor ki Tamam sarhoş
olmalarını ister misiniz askerde Çünkü
Sarhoş olursan seni çok sarhoşluk ne
zaman işe yarar davalarına
inanmıyorlarsa ve talimli değillerse
eğitimde değillerse o zaman istersin şey
olmasın ama askerleri sarhoş olması
istemezsin aynı şekilde istemezsin yani
öfkelenmek bile erdemde olmakla birlikte
uyuş
ama diyebilirsiniz ki yani hiç mi rolü
yok şeylerin bu gibi duygularım
ateşlenmek gibi düşünebilirsiniz bunu
Yani biz hastalandığımızda
aşırı yani ateşlenmeseniz çünkü
vücudunuz savaşmıyor demektir oradaki
enfeksiyonun ama işte Peki şöyle bir şey
dermişsiniz Ya 2 sene oldu Hiç
ateşlenmedim ya ateşlensem böyle
bilemezsin ama hastaysanız ateşlenmeniz
işe yarar aynı onun gibi öfke gibi
duygular korku gibi kalbi gibi duygular
bir gece yaşayamayan insan için Çünkü
adalet duygusu yeterince gelişmediyse
öfkelenmedi ki hakkımı sanıyorsun ya da
başkası hakkını savursun fakat buradaki
bütün amaç Adalet duygusunu geliştirmek
bilgeliği geliştirmek Ve böylece gibi
duygulara akla aykırı duyguları susaca
göre onları bir mesafeden var Onlara
bakmak
peki
Bu nasıl yapılır çok hızlıca söyleyeyim
bazıları ile teknikler de yapılacağını
söylüyorlar bu aynı zamanda bilişsel
davranış psikoterapinin de temellerini
oluşturduğu Düşünsel temellerini
tarihsel olarak oluşturuyor mesela
başımıza gelebilecek bazı kötü şeyleri
önceden göz önünde bulundurmak düşürmek
istiyorum diyorlar buna buna hayali bir
tatbikat ya da hayali olarak aşılanma
yani kafamızı düşünüyoruz başımıza
gelebilecek şeyleri pek şeyi düşünüyoruz
Biraz önce söylediğim sunum yaparken
Başıma gelebilecek Bu yüz kızarması
falan gibi şeylerden bahsetmiştim bize
neyi yapabileceği ile alakalı Yani bana
gerçekten zarar veriyor mu vermiyor
mesela böyle bir şey
bunu düşünmek gönüllü olarak bazen
kendimize sıkıntılara şey yapmak
koşullandırma gelecekte yapacağımız her
şey için yağ olursa gibi hani varsa
yolunda gibi düşünmek ve mantralarda
bazen böyle engelli yola dönüşür gibi
bazı şeyleri kullanmak kendimize
hatırlatmalar kullanmak Bu şekilde
stoacılık bir kişisel dönüşüm felsefesi
ve
malzemelerden inşa etme mutlu ve erdemli
bir hayatı malzeme içimizdeki
malzemelerle başımıza gelenlere
tepkilerimizle İnşaat ve felsefesi
olarak özetleyebilirim teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]